What's up guys? I'm hanging out in Texas today with this guy. You know him hey guys
It's me Brian Brushwood from the modern rogue today. We're hanging out. We're working on making black-Powder fuses. What do you suppose?
We're making fuses. It's almost as though
We're going to detonate
Something neither of us have made this black-Powder fuse before so the purpose of today's experiment is to see if we can get a safety
Fuse that'll work at a consistent rate because we like our fingers, and we'd like to keep them for tomorrow's experiment as well
We're a magician. They're kind of important as we got muzzleloading propellant. You can pick this up at any kind of outdoor store
You can buy it online
I had to pay an extra like
$30 for extra safety handling because it's so flammable and the other thing to note about this is it as
FfG, I specifically asked for triple fG brian. [oh], I typed in what you did, [I'd] I thought it was the right stuff
How many apps do you want? How will he need three [apps]? I don't give enough apparently you don't
Now in addition to the black powder we also went down to the super center and picked up some of this stuff
This is just wrapping paper. It's for a party
[we're] gonna have a party [it] already is a party now that you're here
So we [were] thinking let's cut the tissue paper into strips
Let's pour some black Powder down in the middle of it
And then wrap it over itself twist it up and see if that'll work for a fuse now
Do we have to get it wet or we could do this totally dry?
I have seen some instructions online on how to do this and actually wet down the paper and then pour the powder on I always
Thought that wetting down black powder wasn't necessarily a good thing [however] apparently if you let it dry overnight
It works even better, so let's just go ahead and try both methods and see which one works the best [works] for me now
The powder that we got is actually a lot coarser than we want it to be we need this to be finer powder and this
Is pretty Grainy so we're just going to dump this into a little pyrex container and use the butt end of a hammer?
Kind like a mortar and pestle to crush this up a bit
It's not going to blow up when I do this is it well you're dealing with black powder
So you always want to be prepared [for] the worst [oh] geez but this thing does go up?
We just we're doing it outdoors in a safe area and using a wooden handle so we don't conduct static electricity
But my guess is we're gonna be just we will have remove this to a safer location
Part the finer the powder is the more surface area which means the faster will react and the better it will fit into our
Makeshift views here as well, remember guys black Powders the stuff they used to mine
Or with it blows up rocks. It blows up mountains, and it can blow up you that's encouraging
There we go, so it's not perfect
But you can see we've now reduced our double fG down to about a triple FG equivalent, and that should be enough for our purposes
Well, I tell you what this first one. We made is just dynamite [yeah], that looks beautiful
Let's do that again. So update guys. We have just rolled our first fuse, and I think it's looking pretty good
Yeah, I I'm not entirely sure I think we'll have a surprise ahead of us
But I think wetting it definitely helped it to get nice and snug [and] tight
so it seems like using water on the tissue paper acts as a glue or a binder to keep the paper itself together if you
Were just to put the powder on and try and roll it up all the powder would spill out and you might have
inconsistencies in your fuse and also by rolling it at a 45 degree angle keeps everything twisted nice and tightly together I imagine if we
Try to light this thing off right now actually that's a good except [it]
What would happen if we slid it off right now only one way to find out?
Why don't we break off part of it? I think that's a great idea
Okay, so this is actually still pretty damp to the touch I can feel [it] [sweat]
No way no way
Even while it's wet, and it's actually working like it's not I thought it was gonna. Shoot up and and insipid
That's a pretty slover and infused that's perfect dude will it light up the Powder whoa?
That was amazing
Dude Okay
So that was still wet guys and it still worked. I think we've got a viable idea
I think we can blow everything up right now so update. I cannot believe that [works]
I can't either and it seemed like the water actually
The dampness in no way inhibited the miniature explosions that went all the way down the chain reaction igniting the powder
Yeah, if anything the the fuse burned at like the perfect rate. It wasn't too fast. It wasn't too slow it was very consistent
Yeah, it's the consistency that blew me away [so] cool. So we're gonna do that again
We're gonna make a whole bunch more fuses and after seeing this works. Oh, well. I'm not [gonna] try one without water
I think it works really well
Keeping it Damp. Just helps hold everything down and we just got a really good run with one of those fuses
[so] now we're gonna make them and again [again]. Let's do hold on does go [arts] and [crafts]
So this is the stuff that we ground up, and this is the stuff [that] came out of the container
You can definitely see the difference between the two if that is fine brother. I see what you did there, [ha] ha ha
Wow much faster, but you know what it's not uncontrollably fast. Oh
Why did that go out? Oh there we go?
Whoa nice?
Nicely [done], I'm proud
[I] love how that it's all smoking behind you yeah, give me a glory shot. That's all it was great, okay
So why do you think the few stops?
I think it was loosely packed and not very tight and as a result at some point
There was just enough of a gap that it all fizzled out
[I] agree, so it's very important to make sure our line is consistent
do you think it works like in the cartoons like we could just light that there and it would go all the way across that's
A good question I think it would burn almost the exact same rate as it twisted up, I bet it works
Just like in the cartoons. Just like wiley coyote [gonna] give it a try all right [say] it starts here, and it ends here sure
Dude, just like in the cartoons check it out
Will it jump the gap?
Now it fizzles out that is so cool. [yo], just tells me we just need to roll it tight and yes consistency matters
But as long as you have enough that chain reaction. Just goes just at the perfect few speed
Here's an important part of science that we've just seen in action when black powder is confined. It will explode
But if you put it out in open air it burns at a very consistent rate
It's more like a fast fire than an explosion. That's right
So if we roll that up as long as there are no breaks theoretically
We should have ourselves a pretty good cannon fuse right on all right
So on a scale of one to ten what kind of success. Do you give us well?
I think we're kind of like at a four, but I see potential here, please don't move it did well
[I] think we're [onto] something [I] think this is a viable idea
We made actual black powder fuses
And they worked mostly they seem to be pretty legit these things are still damp as we hold them and yet
They still work so I'm excited to see how they perform tomorrow will they be enough to set off our pyrotechnic device
You're gonna have to fight on the next video because we're gonna be putting these things to the test with coconuts
[just] promise me. I'll still have my fingers
There's no promises with the experiments with your everybody is signing a waiver and you guys while you're at
It click the link in the description go check out the Modern rogue
He does some pretty cool stuff on his channel with his buddy. What'd you guys get up to?
I'm a me and Jason Murphy are on a quest to become the ultimate warrior
Gentlemen and scoundrel making nunchucks out of magazine blowing stuff up
We're trying to be like you kind of to click the link [in] description
Go show them some subscription love and we'll see you tomorrow where we put these things to the test
Thanks for joining us for this experiment. We'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
He gets Dubious to me